يعد معبر رفحاء الحدودي من مصر إلى جنوب غزة
شريان الحياة الإنساني الوحيد لأكثر من
مليوني شخص يعيشون في القطاع المحاصر،
وتقول جمعية الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني إن حوالي 100 شاحنة مساعدات و11
سيارة إسعاف تبرعت بها تركيا تصل إلى غزة
عبر المعبر يوم الجمعة.
وتقول الأمم المتحدة إن رفح هي
المنطقة الحصرية التي يمكنهم من خلالها توزيع المساعدات، وقد اضطروا إلى
التوقف عن توزيعها في سيارات الوحدة
ووسط غزة في الأيام الأخيرة بسبب
شدة القتال هناك. وقد
زار كبار المسؤولين في برنامج الأغذية العالمي غزة يوم الجمعة واجتمعوا مع
السكان وصفوا
مشاهد يائسة لناس ليس لديهم ما يأكلون أو
يشربون، ملاجئ مكتظة وصوت
القنابل تنفجر طوال
اليوم الناس يائسون حقًا وهناك
خوف أه في الهواء هناك
خوف في عيون الأطفال الذي نراه
ويمكنكم تقريبًا  رائحة أه الخوف آه
لا يعرفون إلى أين يذهبون آه
ليس لديهم مكان للإقامة وليس لدينا إجابات
لهم وهذا هو
الجزء الأكثر إحباطًا
حقًا من وجودي هنا وعدم القدرة على
مساعدة kcow انضم إلي مباشرة من القاهرة الآن
في مصر  بعد زيارة V لغزة، كما
ترون، فهو نائب المدير التنفيذي
لبرنامج الأغذية العالمي، شكرًا
جزيلاً لكم على انضمامكم إلينا، ومن الواضح أنكم
تأثرتم كثيرًا بما رأيتموه، هل يمكنكم أن
تصفوا بمزيد من التفصيل ما وجدتموه
مفاجئًا، حسنًا، قمنا بزيارة رافا التي  هي
المدينة الأقرب لحدود مصر
وتعرف أنها مزدحمة حقا هناك
حشود تتحرك من الجنوب أه من
الشمال من أه العملية العسكرية النشطة
أه وفي الناس في
كل مكان أه في الشوارع
والزحمة الملاجئ
مكتظة و  والناس
يخيمون في الشوارع
وهناك حقًا شعور باليأس، كما
تعلمون، لم يتناول الكثيرون الطعام مطلقًا لعدة
أيام. أظهر الاستطلاع الذي أجريناه خلال فترة
التوقف التي استمرت 7 أيام أن نصف
السكان في جاسا يتضورون جوعًا ويعانون من الجوع.  كان هناك
هذا الشعور بالخوف الذي
حاولت شرحه أنه يمكنك رؤية
عيون الناس وتكاد تشم رائحة
ذلك في الهواء وهم يسألوننا هل
تعرف ما الذي سيحدث بجوارنا
وماذا تفعلون وهناك الكثير
بعض
الإجابات التي نرى المساعدات يتم
توزيعها هناك، ربما تكون
المنطقة هي التي تحصل على أكبر قدر من المساعدات أو على الأقل
بعض المساعدات، ما هي القصص التي كنت تسمعها
عن أجزاء أخرى من
الإقليم؟ حسنًا، أستطيع أن أقول إن
العملية الإنسانية مستمرة حقًا
حافة الانهيار، كما تعلمون،
ينهار القانون والنظام أيضًا في
الجنوب وهذا ينبع من هذا
اليأس، حيث لا يأتي ما يكفي من الغذاء
وربما يكون الطعام هو السلعة الأكثر حساسية أه
ولذلك ترون هذا أه
اليأس حول
مواقع التوزيع  لا يعرف الناس متى
سيحصلون على تسليمهم التالي، لذا آه، فأنت
تعلم أن الأمر يقترب من
العنف، ولذا فهو ليس آمنًا
لموظفينا، فهم يعيشون هذه الأزمة حقًا بينما
يحاولون أيضًا معالجتها و
لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى
تغيير تدريجي أه موظفيك شجعان جدًا من
الواضح أنهم يعملون هناك أيضًا لديك
أمراض منتشرة، أليس كذلك ولكن
عندما تكون هناك فوضى وكما تقول أنك
قلق بشأن العنف متى
تتخذ قرارًا بشأن سحب الموظفين
لأنه من
الواضح أنك لن تكون قادرًا على
تحمله جيدًا، كما تعلم، يحاول برنامج wfp دائمًا
البقاء في الكبد أينما
كان وتحت أي ظروف
ولكن الآن نحن نصل إلى حافة الهاوية
كما قلت وأعتقد
ومع ذلك، فإن ما يجلب بعض الأمل هو أنه
خلال تلك الأيام السبعة من التوقف المؤقت،
تمكنا من تقديم الخدمات، وأظهرنا أنه من
الممكن، كما تعلمون، أننا ساعدنا حوالي
مليون شخص في غازا بالفعل منذ
اندلاع الأزمة، بل وتمكنا حتى من
الوصول إلى  الشمال، لذا إذا
سمحت الظروف يمكننا القيام بذلك أه
نحتاج فقط إلى تغيير في البيئة أه
نحتاج إلى العودة إلى أن لدينا
الطعام على الحدود لقد قمنا
بشراء الاستعدادات نحتاج فقط إلى
نقاط الوصول التي نحتاجها  هناك المزيد من المعابر
القادمة
ونحن بحاجة إلى وقف إطلاق نار إنساني حتى
نتمكن من توزيع المساعدات على من هم في
أمس الحاجة إليها في جميع أنحاء غزة